hello and welcome to Backstage the film
and TV podcast from Sky News and your
weekly insight into everything going on
behind and in front of the camera
this week yes you might be able to hear
it Katie Spencer and I are somewhere a
little bit different to usual we are at
the heart of London Film Festival I love
how British it is that every now and
then the location we're in you keep
hearing a tea trolley so if you're
wondering what that noise is it's a
woman that's moving tea around yeah I
mean it has to be done it's a London
Film Festival after all so we need these
sound effects so
um it's and it's we've been enjoying
everything that London Film Festival has
to offer so this week we will be
bringing you all the latest interviews
and reviews with some of the biggest
stars in the world uh including the
likes of Bill Nye
Olivia Coleman Aubry Plaza and Brendan
Fraser
but let's start off with this year's
Best Actress Oscar winner Jessica
Chastain and her new film the good nurse
wow the cross they're really good but
I'm working a lot you still owe me for
last Friday but this can wait really oh
no I'm sorry sorry about that thank you
love you guys
there's lochran this is Officer Braun do
you remember Anna Martinez
yeah it was sudden mind taking a look
the insulin inner system it's a double
medication error which is really rare we
understand that you work with a Charlie
color
could he be involved in this
it was amazing to talk to her to learn
about her I mean there's the the Great
Book Charles scraper's book the good
nurse that really kind of focuses on
Charlie for most of the book and so to
be able to talk to Amy and to understand
what her life was like and what she had
at stake
it really helped me to to realize how
courageous she was and what an
incredible person she is yeah I mean
it's it's she's so strong isn't she yeah
I think you know like many people and
particularly women she's she sort of
comes across as very vulnerable but you
realize she's got this massive strength
underneath yes I mean all the things
that she was juggling at the time also
you know being a single mother to two
girls not having health insurance
um working as a on a night shift so
you're not really getting proper sleep
and also at the same time needing a
heart transplant that's what should we
walk in with at the beginning of this
film
um and then realize I mean without
getting me any spoilers away what she
then stumbles into to is is quite
shocking so the goodness is going to
stream on Netflix on the 26th of October
also here at London Film Festival is
Bill Nye who is promoting his latest
movie living
to be alive for one day
but I realized
I don't know how
[Music]
[Music]
what's incredible about this film it's a
remake of a 1952 Japanese film
um but it was pitched as you know we
should remake this film but set it in
the UK and start Bill Knight so it was
this film was only ever gonna happen if
Bill Nye agreed to the role so she is
the quintessential Englishman it's about
Mr Williams so even his character's name
Williams is a reference to Bill Nye
um he's a sort of lifelong bureaucrat
and he gets diagnosed with a terminal
illness and basically kind of starts
living as the title would suggest
um but it's a really interesting look at
kind of life back then and also a
reminder you know that we all time is
precious and we do need to be careful
about how we spend it
um and everyone is saying an incredible
performance from Bill Nye is incredible
do we think the Oscars I mean it's that
time of the year when I mean now start
wildly speculating yeah my yeah my wild
speculation is yes we're going to see a
Richard E grant-esque run at the Oscars
for this I could see Mr Knight going and
doing all the interviews and the
handshaking and having a one wonderful
time on a kind of
um on a campaign but perhaps uh it won't
be the performance that wins because of
course Brendan Fraser is the sort of
talk
we'll get to that but um I got the
opportunity to chat with him he's always
so lovely and of course this uh was no
different here's what he had to say
bill you are so so great in this film
did you know um straight away when you
were first approached about it did you
know straight away you wanted to do this
one yeah I did I um yeah I did I I met
casual ishiguru the Nobel prize winning
novelist uh for the first time and it
was quite daunting uh and it was his
suggestion he that he'd wanted to uh
transpose the Kurosawa film from Tokyo
to London uh for a while uh and then he
put and then when we met he put it
together with me which was for me
obviously a marvelous development and
he's uh and then he agreed to write the
script he didn't want to write the
script because he said I'm a novelist I
don't you know but then he did and it
was brilliant so everything about it and
then when Oliver Oliver hermanus who uh
we'd seen his previous film Mophie which
he shot with Jamie Ramsey the
cinematographer that made this film and
they uh they came as a as a package and
they would they just turned out to be
completely incredible
so the whole thing was very very
attractive
and what we just mentioned Brendan
Fraser but we should talk about that
he's on the awards Trail for his
performance in the whale
and this is that movie we've been
talking about for ages yeah
uh who doesn't make a bad film does he
well yeah he makes kind of can be
controversial films and I think this is
going to come with some controversy a
couple of critics
um I should say the whale is about a
very very overweight man who's trying to
reconnect with his estranged daughter
and she's a lot of Prosthetics Brendan
Fraser you look at I mean even if you
just look at the trailer it's incredible
he looks yeah like a changed man it's um
yeah it's a hell of a hell of a role for
him yeah a huge physical change as well
as everything else that's going on um
but like I said possibly slightly
controversial a couple of critics I mean
it hasn't been widely seen yet this film
uh but a couple of critics have sort of
said suggested Perhaps it is a bit fat
phobic
the critics that I was reading were
saying it's a little bit to sucker in
and a bit to sort of Twee towards the
end of it but I I think it's just going
to be one that people want to see out of
curiosity exactly that because and
because of Brendan's performance I think
this is the film itself as we're saying
people are quite mixed on but everyone
seems in agreement Brendan's performance
is one that you need to see and one that
he is likely to kind of run away with
the awards for and it's strange going
from like the Wilderness for the last
decade and to the level of attention
that he has got from the film festivals
the standing ovations that he's got and
the same here as well so very unusually
he uh he won the world premiered here he
was given a massive Standing Ovation by
the audience it's not something that
happens that often not a London Film
Festival is it we're usually quite
firmly embedded into our seats it takes
a lot to move us off of our bottom
Hi how are you well massive
congratulations on the film I mean
Awards Oscar balls people screaming your
name how are you kind of finding the
overwhelming support for this movie and
you're rolling I feel very excited I
feel very fortunate I feel very happy to
be here in London
this is this is um
this is more than I ever expected well
deserved as well of course I mean it's
such a it's a physically demanding role
as well as a mental one I'm sure what
was the sort of biggest challenge from
your perspective
the biggest challenge
the biggest challenge wasn't wearing the
makeup and wargobs so much as it was
performing
with an ensemble cast
wonderful for Darren
and telling a story of Tolerance all
shot in a time of covid
so we all know what it was like to live
under those conditions but
it's a film about love at the end of the
day we've just had World mental health
day poor Charlie is really struggling in
the
movie support those that need it I
believe so I think we could do well also
to change the patterns of speech that we
use
when we refer to people who live with
obesity I think that would help too
so this seems like the perfect moment to
bring in Festival director Trisha Tuttle
who was in fact in the room so give us a
sense of what it was like because it you
know like we were saying it is very rare
isn't it to get a standing ovation of
the elephant we don't see that very
often particularly I can't remember the
last time I've seen that at a Gala
screening and uh
definitely definitely people usually
like as the credits are rolling are
leaving and what was amazing is we
didn't realize Brendan was going to sit
in and he sat in and um I had a
suspicion that if people realized that
he was sitting there it's such a
terrific performance that they were
going to be really knocked out and
respond to it so we were like standing
by but I did not expect literally no one
left the cinema and it went on for five
minutes and he just brings out this love
in people and he deserves all the
plaudets he gets for the performance as
well
it just seems like such a thoroughly
nice map
everything you see is absolutely genuine
and even afterwards as you know it took
him a minute to to pull himself together
because he was very touched by the
response that he got from the crowd
how's he going to cope going into the
Oscars I don't think he's going to
toughen up he's a he's a you know a
heart on his sleeve kind of human being
I think which is why people love it well
that's it I think people will really
enjoy watching that campaign you know
there'll be lots of interviews of
handshaking and I think you know fans
that could happen to a nicer human yeah
yeah I totally agree yeah
um and so how how is the festival going
at this point we're sort of heading
towards the end as we as we record this
podcast you're slightly losing your
voice
every year we know we've passed halfway
when I've started losing my voice so
yeah day day eight and it's gone I mean
I couldn't have hope for a better
Festival it's been amazing
um every night has been really special
something different happening all over
the city but also UK wide screenings as
well too so I know I probably have an
appalling shot her memory but this year
seems just such an interesting mix of
films that you've got such a good strong
year isn't it it feels like that to us
so I'm glad that that's um that you
you're getting that as well too we're
really excited I mean we're always
really interested in the breadth of
Cinema documentary fiction artist moving
image and now of course we have XR and
immersive in series as well too but it
does feel like there's so much sort of
Rich variety of you know formal but also
International diversity as well too
great writing great school great writing
you know what I've been really pleased
about as well too is how foregrounded
Riders have been in during this Festival
so in the last couple of days we've had
Samuel D Hunter who wrote the whale and
Christopher Hampton who worked on the
sun with Florian Zeller and you know
tonight we have Rebecca lenkovitz or
tomorrow night we have Rebecca lenkovitz
who wrote she said it's really
interesting to see how great the writing
is and how directors are really sharing
that Spotlight with their creative
collaborate writers as well it's also
it's also super Starry one I feel like
every single day there's just a massive
A-list celebrities in town that must be
very um it shows the support for the
festival the fact that you know these
a-listers some of whom are working on
other projects are actually taking the
time to come in Walk the carpets uh for
for the festival no it's really exciting
I mean I think that speaks to how we've
grown the festival as well too it's a
important moment to launch a film into
quite often the awards the awards season
um and it really you know London is such
a vibrant production Hub as well lots of
people are here this is a second home to
lots of people as well and that really
um it feels like I think a lot of talent
feel like they're coming to their second
home when they come here as well at a
time when Cinema is struggling or
independent Cinemas and what have you it
just does bring home how important it is
to actually physically be out and in the
cinema and definitely and I think you
know that's something that we've been
really thinking about a lot this week I
know lots of the UK have with a Film
Festival closing and Beautiful film
house and the Belmont and Aberdeen and
it you know I I'm really aware that how
precious it is and how fragile it is too
we need to get audiences to understand
like remember not understand remember
what a pleasure it is to see a film with
together in cinema now we don't want to
get all Misty either but it is also your
last hello
after a massive 10 years
um and then we've talked about kind of
the Rarity of the the kind of exciting
moments like Brendan Fraser's founding
of ocean earlier are there any other
kind of real standout moments or kind of
fun little excerpts that you that you
would like to highlight from yours
another moment um well it's a couple of
moments I think one I'd say it was I was
Deputy head of festivals in my
predecessor Claire Stewart was the
director and the day we showed Whiplash
um and no one had heard of Damien
chazelle and people just went crazy and
we sort of thought that he would get
that kind of response so we did a rare
thing and brought him back at the end of
the screening and it was one of the
those moments but you know that's been
like seven or eight years ago and then
another moment that was really special I
think was when we had Lady Bird and
Greta go wig and so sharonan came back
it was our surprise film so no one knew
what they were going to see and they
came back afterwards and had that kind
of rapturous response as well too those
are really special precious moments but
you're thinking back it's like wow yeah
it's a it's become a quite an important
stop on the uh Film Festival circuit
hasn't it London so I think so in this
year we have um we're launching a number
of film films as World premieres on
Saturday we've got um Guillermo del
Toro's Pinocchio which we're really
looking forward to and um yeah and we've
also on that same day we've got um Asif
kapadia and Akram Khan's collaboration
creature which is a world premiere so
the festival is growing and developing
as well too you're leaving on a high I
am so jumping off on a high and that
feels really great you know it's like
I'm I'm excited to see what what new
people do and the incredible team that I
work with I mean I'm very visible but it
is it takes a lot of really great people
to run a festival like this and they're
going to be here still delivering the
Great Festival you'll still come back
yeah I am going to be sitting I've
already said there's a new rule that ex
Festival directors get a free pass for
10 years yeah but we will let you go
before your UH your voice goes
completely but thank you so much Aubrey
Plaza next with her new film Emily the
criminal
Hi I paid 400 and it was not replied to
my balance
sorry how much uh interest is being
added a month
how are you
I need a real job just to like pay my
loans Emily yo
let me hook you up
in the next hour you will make 200 cash
but you have to do something illegal you
won't be in danger but you will be
breaking the law yo you gonna pay for
that
sorry a bit of a gear change this is a
sort of Thriller from Aubry Plaza who
lots of people will know from Parks and
Recreation
but this is a very different role for
her she's playing it's a really
interesting film because it's sort of it
starts off being a film you'll recognize
about a woman who can't pay her bills
and is forced to turn to a life of crime
and that's all is often the setup for a
film but what makes this quite
interesting is she she really leans into
it she realizes she enjoys this method
of making money and perhaps it's you
know a better way for her than uh going
down the corporate route um so I I think
it's it's a it's a good movie and it's
it's something a little bit different at
the film festival read and interviews
with her she now believes she's picked
up skills that if it doesn't work out
she can take to a life of crime she'll
be what a useful
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and when I caught up with Aubrey she
talked about how it was an opportunity
to do something that is quite different
for her
Aubrey for you was it like me watching
it were you like well I can't really
think of a time I've seen a character
quite like this before yes absolutely
when I read it I was like wow this is
really unique and
um a really different kind of character
for me to play
um I loved her immediately yeah is it
sort of are you kind of quite conscious
when you're looking at roles to do
things so you don't end up sort of doing
the same thing over and over definitely
yeah yeah it's hard in Hollywood in the
industry because people see you do one
thing you know and then they want they
just want you to do it over and over
again or something so it's always hard
to kind of yeah show people
all sides of yourself so I'm always
looking to do something different I
never want to do the same thing
so one of the many films getting a
Premiere at London Film Festival is my
placement and I'm delighted to say we're
now joined by Gina Mckee who is one of
the fabulous stars
um it's not the world premiere is it
Gina because it has already had one
Premiere in Toronto so you know all this
is feeling kind of uh quite quite
familiar now no not familiar not
familiar this is a premiere on home turf
um so yeah the Toronto Film Festival you
had the world premiere this is the
second time that people can have an
opportunity to see it tomorrow oh no
Saturday here at the London Film
Festival I mean for you as well this is
a film that's been so talked about we
should say because of a certain leading
man that's in it Mr Harry Styles is it
weird to be in a film with Harry Styles
where people are just talking so much
about this Mega star that is cast in
these films um Harry it's brilliant to
have Harry on board because obviously
see it means that it's going to reach a
huge audience which is just very special
so we're really privileged to have that
access but he's an amazing person and
he's very grounded and he's really
really wonderful and special and so you
know
you've worked with some huge co-stars
over the years but surely the level of
attention that he receives is it sort of
Next Level when you kind of see how he's
having to deal with well it's
interesting Harry deals with it
brilliantly I mean genuinely
impressively and when we're at the
Toronto Film Festival there was a lot of
people there to see him a lot of young
women mainly and when he stepped out
I've never heard a sound like honestly I
think every dog in Toronto must have
been going out because this pitch of
squealing was extraordinary and it was
sustained and he's amazing the way he
deals with it and communicates with
people and he's just a very special
person give us a sense What It's Like on
a red carpet because we sometimes are on
the you know the interviewing side but
you're actually walking down and you
know like you say people are very
excited and it's such a it's such a kind
of Starry moment how do you kind of find
it that sort of process of premiering
the film it's it's interesting because
it's a work event really because you're
having to you know talk to people and so
there's like a two-fold element often
going on and in my case a three-fold
element because there's like this sort
of outer body thing thinking wow this is
a bit odd
um so it's intense and
um exciting and yet at the same time you
have to be very focused so it's a funny
old combination how's it going to get
this film now in front of audiences as
well for people that won't know explain
a bit about my policeman as well my
policeman is based on a book by Beth and
Roberts and um it's essentially three
people who meet in the 1950s in Britain
in fact in the south coast in Brighton
in England and they're brought together
I'm going to be cautious about what I
say because I don't want to give too
much away but they're brought together
by love
and they form this triangle and they
have a friendship and relationships
which mark them for life and in the
1990s in fact in 1999 you they meet
again
to reconcile perhaps the last 40 years
because you're sort of sharing a
character with Emma Corin so talk to us
about that kind of collaboration I
assume you've chatted a lot about kind
of how to make sure that you know it was
authentically played the same person
with her and
with them and you so yeah we've got the
three characters so Tom is as in the
1950s is played by Harry and then later
by Linus roach and then Patrick who's
played by David Dawson and then later by
Rupert Everett and then as you mentioned
Emma Corin plays the Young
Marion and I play ho in the 1999 version
and we shot this film in 2021 so
pandemic was still a huge issue in terms
of dealing with covert and so we were
being very cautious we had lots of
criteria at work about what we couldn't
couldn't do and so we only ever met on
Zoom initially and that was only a few
occasions and they shot the 1950s stuff
largely they shot most of the 1950s
stuff first and then in a separate
bubble if you like we then shot the 1999
stuff and so our director Michael
grandage gave the older counterparts
maybe like four scenes that were rough
cut which had our counterparts in so we
could watch those we obviously liaised
with the makeup designer and the costume
designer a lot in terms of finding
parallels and a narrative there whether
that was useful or not and we relied
heavily on Michael our director who was
the conduit
and then once quite by accident I bumped
into Emma in the Street in Brighton when
we're filming and that's the first time
we physically matched I mean she was
there kind of work it was like a
crossover time but I was just stepping
up for some lunch and we bumped into
each other and
um so it was an interesting thing
because ordinarily I'm sure we would
have had much more in-person
collaboration but I watched a lot of
Emma's work I'd obviously I've obviously
seen the crown but I looked again and I
watched interviews that she did anything
just to sort of I don't know see if
there was something there that might be
useful
and how has it been to to see the
audience reaction as well I guess to
finally sort of have it at least film
festivals to well we've only ever had
the screening at Toronto and we were
busy doing interviews so we couldn't be
and in fact that night very lovely we
received an award from the Toronto
International Film Festival which was um
the very first I believe certainly for
them
um Ensemble award for the cast and so
the ceremony for that award was the
evening of our premiere so we had to nip
off to say thank you and then receive
the award but we've got stuck in an
elevator
yeah
I kept thinking
anyways we did get out eventually and we
did get to the stage on time so we
haven't I haven't been in a space with
an audience yet so lff you'll just be
relieved to not be stuck in a lift and
hopefully actually
so Saturday that would be the first time
oh well enjoy it thank you so much
so if you want to find out more about
this year's London Film Festival head to
the link in the description below my
thanks to everyone who's spoken to us
and of course to Trisha Tuttle
particularly you can listen to Backstage
the TV and film podcast from Sky News
every week wherever you get your
podcasts bye
let's go